there's no better moment for me on a set
then when you know our key grip comes up
to me in the morning and and shakes my
hand looks like let's do it yeah Mike
let's do it baby Mike Anderson hey
that's roll you know that's it Basquiat
was not my first roll on film but it was
my first lead I had literally just put
in my letter of resignation from Angels
in America on Broadway I'd been doing it
for about a year and a half and it came
back home and there was a message it was
from a friend of mine named Randy
Sabu sawa who had been a producer for
Abel Ferrara and other things and he
said Geoffrey I'm helping casting folks
find someone to play jean-michel
basquiat and I thought of you and I just
wanted to give you the heads up you know
give me a call let me know he think and
I heard that message and I immediately
knew that that was the next thing that I
was going to do hey Benny man how long
do you think it takes to get famous
famous for years they asked me to come
in and read Benny to read the role that
Benicio del Toro ultimately played and
I'm like ah so we went down to Julian
Schnabel's house who directed it but I
took it upon myself to read Benny's role
as I would read you all Michele Basquiat
and the next day or I think he was even
like after I got home from that read
Julianne called me and asked me if I
would consider playing that role and
no way we went ride with the devil
so this was after I'd done Basquiat and
my agent called and said Angley wants to
meet with you Anglian James Seamus they
don't want to send the script but they
have this Civil War film my own so I
went over to their office over on Canal
Street and we sat down and talked and I
realized the reason that they didn't
want to send the script is because they
thought it might be misperceived was a
story civil war story but told from the
perspective of the South set during the
Kansas Missouri border war which was
kind of an irregular war on the
outskirts of the boundaries of our
country at that point in on the
boundaries of this war it was the place
where a lot of the outlaws of the Old
West made their names Jesse James Wild
Bill Hickok all of these type folks were
involved in this anyway I played a role
that was based on a real character named
Nolan if I'm not mistaken who was a
scout for Quantrill who raided Lawrence
Kansas he was a commander of the
southern forces over there pretty
controversial guy but my character
Daniel holed his fighting on the side of
Confederacy not because he has
allegiance to the principles of slavery
and the principles of free South but
because he had personal relationships
with folks who were involved in the war
guy that he grew up with his family was
attacked and hold goes out and tries to
fight on behalf of his friend and why is
it getting caught now he's riding with
the devil
and what I loved about the story was
that it was a story about our history
about racial dynamics within our history
it was a story about slavery and
emancipation but from Holt's perspective
it was a story about his own
emancipation it was not a story about
the great white savior rescuing him from
his burden from his shackles it was
about him having to navigate his way
through very nuanced and complex reality
and emerge out of it whole fully human
and free and it's one of my favorite
films that I've done it's a beautiful
film I encourage you to check it out
last film of the 20th century about the
American Civil War but told from the
perspective of Angley in a kind of de
Tocqueville way you know outsider
looking in and shining some very
interesting and and probing light on the
subject
shaft people love people's he's a man of
the people's people's people like the
bad guys I found it's an interesting
dynamic they dig the bad guys he
certainly was that branch office a big
lawyer lawyers of a pinatas I thought
you were gonna smoke smoke calm people's
is dominican born in the Dominican
Republic came to the States at some
point lives up in Washington Heights so
I went on journeys up there but there
was one individual in particular who
really influenced me I used to go to a
place in Midtown particularly when I was
doing shows on Broadway it's called a
lone Star Boat Club azole men's club
where Walter Matthau at Sullivan all of
these guys used to go there was a guy
who managed the whole place named
Raphael
fee Rafi was Dominican and because I
used to come to the club late
Rafi would say to me for example he say
Jerry he say you you turning into a one
by you know like Dracula with the fangs
you why why only you know so Rafi was
the clarion bell for peoples he was the
one who gave me the voice and in fact
when I got the script I said Rafi here
man would you read you know a couple of
these lines read this Reno and he came
over and I recorded him so I Oh Rafi
much of people's language and voice
boycott got a call from Clark Johnson I
want you to play King and I'm like I was
like oh wow and you know in fact the
first thing I said was like you know
Kings you know we're a different you
know shade of of a brother you know and
I thought I might be a little lighter
than what was required although I'm
blue-black in my brain but Clark said
that we were gonna do this not based on
the color of skin but on the content of
character I was like yeah yeah I can't
argue with you you know that's you know
Touche
so I agreed to do it and I stayed in the
Sun as much as I possibly could to do at
least that part as much justice as
possible
very good went down to to Atlanta to
film that and it was interesting doing
Mark Antony just before doing that film
because of course you know Mark Antony
is is known for his famous oration in
Caesar and there has been no greater
orator in the history of our country
than Martin Luther King so it was
actually an interesting warm up
rehearsal process for that role
what I found however was I was just
overwhelmed by an appreciation for the
capacity of his breath to be able to
deliver those speeches often impromptu
in the way that he did with such force
such power first sin I have committed is
being born a Negro the second sin I have
committed along with all of us is to
object to the twin battering-rams of
segregation and depression the breath
required was exhausting but we went at
it and I had been rehearsing that role
since I could remember in some ways
because I was always just in love with
who he was with his voice with his words
with his writing I was taught in tenth
grade by one of my favorite teachers in
high school dr. Paul Piazza he would
teach us with King about repetition and
adoration and imagery and all of these
things so yeah just threw myself into
that plus I was really trying to impress
my co-star who's playing Coretta Scott
King Carmen ejogo so you know I was I
was you know I was at 125 miles an hour
I was on it because of course she later
became the mother of my children and my
wife Angels in America 10 years exactly
after I started with the production on
Broadway year-and-a-half on Broadway
seven our play
new that piece pretty well by the time
we came to filming there was a
difference only in that it was on film
so the performance is told through an
aperture as opposed to through a
proscenium stage to 800 people or
however many people we had at Walter
Kerr any given night it's more distilled
performance quieter at times also my
hair was different and of course MacLean
with a different set of actors I had the
good fortune to be the only one from the
Broadway production that was in the film
that color is Mose Al Pacino as the
dreaded Roy Cohn and Meryl Streep Emma
Thompson and Shankman and justing
wonderful gathering of folks Mike
Nichols directing whereas Ron Liebman
the late recently late Ron Lehmann
beautiful extraordinary powerful crazy
ironic wonderful horrible brilliant
performance of his by Roy Cohn within
playing with the Al Pacino who is all
those things as well that pieces is kind
of the center of my career or it's the
epicenter anyway it's where it's where
it all begins with that experience on
Broadway and then continuing into the
film I Oh Tony Kushner and George Woolf
who directed the play I owe them a lot
in terms of what I am as a creative
person and what I am as uh as a human
being maybe one of the most human
pieces that will ever be written poems
James Bob I got a call and my agent said
yeah they want you to do the James Bond
movie they you know they're gonna send
over the script
Barbara broccoli called and so you know
they're saying like some CIA guy or
something so you know take a look at it
when you get it so the script arrives
I'm like bro CIA
let's felix leiter man what yeah I'll do
that
but of course originally played by Jack
Lord you know from y5o in the shades and
everything Sean Connery funny came right
through sorry should've introduced
myself things were related if you look
Slater
my brother from Langley
you should have a little faith you keep
your head about you I think you had them
the way that I kind of thought about him
was in some ways in relationship to what
Daniel was doing he was bringing a
different level of authenticity to his
bond a guy that you could kind of
picture yeah I can actually picture that
guy in a back alley like getting down
you know he ain't kind of an edge to him
and so I wanted to make sure that Felix
has to be kind of grounded you know and
a guy that you could picture like
creeping in the shadows
one of those guys you know not you know
kind of like a diplomatic type level guy
but an underbelly guy you know who can
handle himself and do it you know with
my own flavor oh gee oh gee was a film
like no other I've been a part of not
because of me so much is because of my
co-stars and my colleagues my fellow
actors who were all men incarcerated
most of them still incarcerated as we
speak and so they were mentors to me
through this process they were expert
consultants throughout this thing they
were colleagues they were incredibly
supportive incredibly engaged in the
process Theotis Carter who plays Beecher
who I have most of the screen screen
time with was the most intense
individual actor I've ever shared the
space with no one comes close no one
else and I've worked with
the greats he had such a profoundly deep
reservoir of emotion they all did when
they laughed the laughter would come
from deep within them and kind of things
would just reverberate when he got angry
anger and he did a couple of times with
me I say United near in ten a week Terry
sent you hey I'm not your man younger
not easy giving a performance it's
tedious it's long hours they've got a
lot of time yes but we were you know 14
sometimes 16 hours a day working on this
it's repetitive it's specific your
understanding of it evolves over time
and the tools that you need to be able
to shape it and all that and he just
absorbed and he wanted it so badly and
he does a wonderful job and he's said
this very specifically and what he might
have done if he had had an opportunity
like that prior to being inside pendulum
Pendleton correctional facility outside
Indianapolis Indiana
his story was very much like the stories
of many all of the men almost
universally whether they be white
because we was a pretty even split there
and that we were in Indiana you had
rural poor rural disadvantaged your
urban disadvantage and they had a shared
story of instability at childhood of
absence of opportunity of drug use of
parental abuse or neglect and an utter
chaos and incarceration the prior to
incarceration some pretty heinous crimes
but at the same time some of them are
working toward a very difficult
Redemption inside and this film we hope
to be part of that in some way the thing
about those guys is they know their
stories and if politicians the
legislators took time to really
understand those guys to go to prison
talk to them we could shape change in
this country relative to violence and
criminality incarceration in a way that
would be unbelievably transformative and
positive and productive for all of us we
could create a safer less violent
society by listening to them how they
got there you know you're not to like
them but they certainly can tell you how
they went wrong and how society went
wrong in creating them Boardwalk Empire
people do like bad guys or drawn bad
guys but I wanted to make him so
villainous that he was just absolutely
loathsome
because he's just so hypocritical and
and so actively works with enthusiasm
and delight to betray everything that he
pretends to hold so dear we have no
quarrel mr. purnsley how about you
getting even for Dickie pastor that
account has been settled and in any
event it was mainly financial in nature
I'm here on new business and everything
that he holds up as the pinnacle of
citizenship he works actively to
undermine daily and he Gavin you know
that's just that's just so beautifully
loathesome so yeah dr. Narcisse
Westworld I was sent the first script
again agent hey Jonah Nolan wants to
Skype with you talk to you about this
new show you know Anthony Hopkins is on
board nobody else really yet you know
you want to talk to him yeah okay I'm
not doing anything right now yeah yeah I
hadn't seen the movie Westworld before
so I watched that and then Jonah and I
had a chat and then after that sent me
the script just the first episode oh
this is really something because the
architecture of that first episode was
very well considered very specific and
played into the storytelling in a way
that kind of indicated to me where the
show might go so uh yeah Jonah count me
in i sided myself we were taking a more
disciplined approach here
I suppose self-delusion is a gift of
natural selection as well
indeed it is I started filming shot the
pilot and I still you know Lisa you know
Jonah ho Bernard's you know it's very
understated
he's an understated guy you know just
kind of you know spinning his hamster
wheel doing his thing detective you know
brilliant guy just trying to sort out
you know all the you know look after the
park okay great yeah cool but
understated okay cool
boom then you know we got picked up to
come back so I think we came back like
in May I think of the next year 2015
maybe something like that we start
rehearsing and Lisa joy calls me in to
into her office she's like Oh Jeffrey
how can I say well what is it oh okay
all right let me tell you you're gonna
get Bernards a host what oh okay
and so that was my little secret seed
kernel in my hard drive from then on
that no one else knew no one else knew I
don't think even Tony knew no he didn't
know Anthony Hopkins and and so you know
helps Bernard but you know on a journey
of discovery about what is what is he
what is his being what his humanity kind
of discover what humanity is so that he
might be able to understand himself as
he tries to replicate it kind of like an
actor maybe but that's good ol Bernard
yeah we'll see where he goes from here
but this year this season of course the
show is taken on you know a different
tone it's a new world and it just looks
new it feels new
it looks like freshly blown glass it's
just gorgeous man it's just like
refracting and all this stuff
and it's complex show huge sprawling so
many moving parts and hundreds of pairs
of hands and brains working to get it
done just the collaboration you know the
circle of artists and creative folks and
carpenters and electricians all creative
as well and craftsmen who work on our
show and writers coming together and
actors of course coming together to
create this world that really haven't
even for and to be in the center of that
when the camera is on you and time to
roll and to take on that responsibility
and everybody looking around note okay
we're moving the ball down the field
right now let's go and you hit it it's
just so great it's just so great hi GQ
I'm Jeffrey right and also want to talk
a little bit about some things that are
happening right now if you are self
isolated if you're quarantined right now
if you want to figure out a way to to be
helpful feel involved in in this fight
go to our GoFundMe page Brooklyn for
life you can google that or my name it
go fund me and contribute to our effort
to feed health care workers here in
Brooklyn by raising money that goes to
providing meals to five Brooklyn
hospitals seven EMS stations now all
meals provided by local small business
turns so every every dollar that's
raised will go to those restaurants to
keep them afloat so they can keep our
warriors on the frontline fed and
support it so show a little love thank
you and if you're outside if you've if
you've passed this kovat phase that
we're experiencing now just remember we
made it and we didn't make it without
the support the hard work the dedication
of the heroes on the front lines our
nurses our doctors all the workers in
hospitals are EMTs and paramedics
everybody on the front line Bravo to
them thank you all and let's carry on